no it's the Biebs and Justin Gordon your
carpool karaoke that is so funny
hey baby
you're exporting wow talk about a
delight Justin Bieber and James Corden
are teaming up for yet another
installment of carpool karaoke it's
always good right
yeah it looks like we're gonna get some
dance moves
check out justin teaching james some
choreo
oh and this time they're serving snacks
from the inside of a yummy food truck
get it yummy
[Music]
and by the looks of it they had a ton of
fans lined up to get in on the food
can't blame them for that thanks James
posted this pic of Justin kissing his
cheek
riding a big day the Biebs took to
Instagram to share these shots writing
quote stay on the lookout for James
Corden coming up oh and can we please
talk about that apron and the matching
baseball cap amazing
this van caught some of the action on
video and I think the most surprising
thing is that James isn't actually
driving okay I guess it's not that
surprising
hashtag safety first this is not the
first time the Biebs has done carpool
karaoke his first appearance was in 2015
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
still so good of course justin has got a
lot to promote right now he's gearing up
to release a new album
I can never remake this um it's gotta be
perfect Oh weird I'm excited just
nervous a little bit this album is
different because of where I'm at in my
life and a YouTube documentary you want
to start by talking about the last four
years Wow as humans we go through so
many ups and downs so many good seasons
bad seasons
you know sometimes we want to give up no
word on when his episode of carpool
karaoke will air but we know he's the
musical guest on Saturday Night Live On
February 8th with RuPaul as a host I
cannot wait I love to work out so it's
perfect all right guys that's it for
today for all the latest on the Biebs
stick with et until next time I'm Katie
Krause and bye for now
[Music]